Since I spoke with you two weeks ago, I have had only one day without any panic attacks.
I believe it is because I had a handful of friends praying for me on that day.
Out of desperation, the panic is tormenting.
So this tells you the power of prayer that can be extremely beneficial in anything,
because God can change anything even our physiology since he is our stator of every cellular function that we have.
But just I'm going to actually have some videos up on the chronic,
chronic disease and autoimmune site on this, but here's one of the slides here,
that are unhealthy to understand what are called mood disorders.
So don't be thrown by that terminology.
It doesn't mean you have a bad mood or something like that,
but that's what's called a mood disorder where you have depression, anxiety, CD,
panic attacks, those are all classified in the mood disorder category.
And here's one of the slides on this section that I will be doing soon and enter it,
and might even be its own module on mood disorders in the chronic disease thing.
So what are we looking for when a person has panic attacks?
Because we have several questions on panic attacks, anxiety, and OCD the last few weeks.
So there can be neurochemical imbalances.
So you could have issues with so neurochemicals.
So when you're taking supplements, you're trying to alter chemistry.
So when you're taking a drug, you're trying to alter chemistry.
So neurochemical, there's chemistry in your brain.
There's chemistry that alters nerve function and you always think of neurotransmitters.
Well, that's just one piece of it.
So it can be a neurotransmitter imbalance.
So this talks about serotonin imbalance, dopamine, gamma, acetylcholine, epinephrine.
Those are all neurotransmitters.
But there can be other hormonal balances, imbalances there that are chemicals that affect the brain.
From, you know, we discussed, I think last week we had this question about hormone imbalances that can affect the brain.
Could be sugar imbalances.
Could be neuroinflammation.
There can be a gut brain access disorder.
All these things need to be fared out into their own slide presentation.
I have an entire presentation on neuroinflammation and microglial primate.
That goes into one cause of any type of mood disorders, but it also is a cause of dementia issues.
It's a cause of Parkinson's issues.
What you have inflammation in the brain from some reason that can affect the microglial cells that can affect.
So you actually developing antibodies to neural tissue.
So we're going to, another question was asked, what test, what kind of test do we test for this?
I'll get to that in just a second, but this is where we can test for antibodies to neural tissue.
So there's a Cyrex antibody test, Cyrex array 7x, that can be very valuable, can really get it into diagnosed.
What is causing this?
If it is, and basically an autoimmune issue in the brain, you can have a brain injury issue.
So a brain injury due to trauma, post traumatic injuries, post-concussive injuries.
A lot of information on post-concussive syndrome, person that has had multiple minor concussions.
I don't even remember being knocked out when I played soccer for years in high school and college.
You're heading the ball all the time.
You had all these little micro-biter concussions that then can now ferret out as inflammation in the brain 15, 25 years later.
And now you're having all these issues that you never would have attributed back to that time.
Or you had a very serious concussion.
I had a really bad car accident when I was 25.
It took a long time to recover, but gosh, that was 25 years ago.
How can that be a cause of it?
Well, you can have damage to microglial cells, and then they can stay in this certain crime state,
and they're just spewing out inflammation, and that can end up with other issues.
Trauma or toxin exposure or emotional issues can then spark an autoimmune issue.
And now you've developed antibodies to neural tissue, and that's causing massive symptom, symptomology.
You can have neurodegenerative issues, so you can have degeneration in the brain.
Usually, again, that's caused from back to the neuroinflammation that was the piece of that,
but then causing antibodies to be developed to neural tissue, and then destructive loss of myelin sheets or destructive loss of neural tissue.
And every time you spark an immune reaction, you're destroying that, which you have antibodies against it,
if you have antibodies against neural tissue, you're going to have destruction of brain matter.
Then we get into the neurodevelopmental disorders.
That's not going to be anybody that we're really, really related to here.
That's going to be a younger person.
And then you have psychological issues.
We have issues of stress.
We have issues of emotional traumas, and that's where you get into post-traumatic stress issues.
All those play a part, and we can't, you know, you got a cancer diagnosis.
That plays a huge part into spurring on something that was already there, and maybe somewhat latent for a period of time.
Now you got the stress of a cancer diagnosis, and it just spews on this inflammation at a greater...
propensity towards these mood disorders that maybe you didn't have prior to this.
And then you get into the neurological autoimmune diseases that I touched out, and that's where testing for those can be wise.
That was the question about testing.
Also the things that you want to test for, one of the other things on this slide was this got brain access disorder that's very, very common.
That's another thing to test for.
So compare sites in the gut cause mood disorders.
Yes, because that could cause inflammation in the brain.
Can a person get parasites in the brain?
Yes, they can that can cross the blood brain barrier.
Can the source be like a vaccine that causes that the adjuvings cross the blood brain barrier?
Yes.
Can toxins damage the blood brain barrier, and then therefore cross the blood brain barrier, cause inflammation of the brain?
So testing stool sample for parasite, testing for pathogens, microtoxins, or a big cause of brain inflammation and microglial primate.
So some of the tests that you would run besides antibody tests to neural tissue, in the case that I mentioned the CyRX7X, another test you would run would be parasite tests.
And then food sensitivity tests.
So if I have antibodies to, let's say, gluten, or gliadine peptides, and I'm eating gluten every time I eat that, I'm causing an inflammatory reaction in my gut.
And then I actually have gluteal morphine receptors in my gut that fire in my brain, I'm going to be causing inflammation in my brain.
And it's like that with so many other foods, you could be eating, you know, a good food.
Let's say broccoli, and I don't have any gut issues when I eat broccoli, but if you have antibodies to broccoli, you're going to be causing inflammation in the brain every time you eat that.
So remember, inflammation in the gut is going to equal inflammation in the brain.
So if you're, if you're something is damaging, you're got, or causing an inflammatory reaction, you're got, you're going to have inflammation in the brain, and it is going to come out in different ways, depending upon any other pre-existing issues that you have with neural tissue.
Digging into doing some testing is the next step.
If you can't counteract it with, you know, just some, let's, let's try to heal your gut.
Let's try to get rid of inflammation. Let's try to deal with parasites.
You know, it'd be better to run some labs to get into the bottom of it.